sí no
es libre
y
si lo menos
y este hecho
[Música]
reunión
simplemente algunos de ustedes recuerden
que sus madres jugaban con ustedes de
esta manera
abencia y juego bueno y poesía nuestros
primeros encuentros con la poesía pero
antes de eso
de la madre
y uniones del abismo de superación y
podríamos sentir locales
en su sangre corriendo cerca de nosotros
allí tuvimos la primera experiencia
política quiero pedirles por favor que
cierren sus ojos son momentos
ni
está bien
ahí estamos
mamá solo
con sugerencia por la dulzura de la
verdad
esta es lo que hace la poesía la poesía
es germán te encontrarás con ustedes que
querían la poesía es capaz de
permitirnos seguir en nuestro lugar
es que quieren trabajar en el sitio del
hombre
[Música]
la primera vez
sí
[Música]
es realmente terminado y fue preguntarme
qué les iba a vender
y tú
si debiendo en cambios sustantivos los
verbos los adverbios como suele suceder
en las escuelas
pero no
esta vez mi poesía sólo vivía jugar y
así antes
20 57 minutos
yo llegaba leyó poema para ellos y
durante tres semanas
[Música]
por la ventana
ellos dicen
yo lo he visto y así la poesía les
permitió ver su realidad de otra manera
una manito propia y sin seso
y todos
en el libro decían eso
yo no sé por qué digo pues porque en los
libros no dicen cosas vendidas
tan amantes yo les contaba un punto del
pueblo que íbamos a leer
así desmonte que la siguiente vez le
diríamos a miguel más grandes
quién puede español el pasado de rebaños
y diversas después de que me gana más
cuando su hijo nació estaba en la
canción
porque mirando fundada con el gobierno
que existía en ese momento de semana
en holanda
en firmantes de 2005 el reino unido
así que en cuanto termine me dijeron si
estás en forma acumulada
[Música]
m
y windows
nuevamente les presente un soneto de
miguel hernández el siguiente martes
tiempo el nadie
antes era la última oportunidad que iba
a encontrarse por miguel hernández
así que
y donde se verá para ellos las mamás de
la cebolla
yo sé a mí que estamos comiendo en
pierna
en cualquier momento si ellas no les
gusta
[Música]
y contando entre 30 estrofa
cuando miguel hernández dice tú estarás
en mí reponer las soledades grita cárcel
blanca
en el silencio del salón
[Música]
y todos
contamos
suspendidos en esa emoción
una mente
y para los chicos
yo
hoy día iba dándoles posibilidades de
comunicarse la bolsa iba entregando la
espalda a las nuevas los chicos que
querían lamentamos incluso que algunos
de ellos ya verían a su padre a ti
porque les comenté que hubo es un
municipio en el que como muchos
municipios de nuestro país en el
conflicto político militar ha sido muy
fuerte solamente
bueno efectivamente así ha sido y además
la construcción de la represa de betania
también ambiente en su trabajo
la bolsa empezó a ganar
lo que sentía
y cada antes entonces yo llevaba un
poema nuevo como ustedes saben las
palabras sirven para decir lo que
necesitamos decir pero también
[Música]
argentino jugamos con buena cosa yo sé
que ustedes también han jugado a ellos
así que los invito a leer más
y punto
[Música]
si se permite a ratos
pero todo
[Música]
la gente por el punto
muerte más
la gente ama
si título
parece nuevamente
o simplemente consiste
sí pero que sí
ojalá que ya está loco pero no más de
mando así
entonces se juega con la poesía pero más
bien persona porque luego los emite o
necesita los poemas de libre en
la aduana
y fue más y más con el cuerpo por el
propósito de que el conocimiento que
atraviesa el cuerpo realmente nos
atraviesa para siempre y sin vivir dice
así
de una semilla
y gana
divina
y la sal
en la sala
en la cara
y otra vez a comenzar que van a servir
conmigo en sentencia es para nada
y la sal
y massa
i
maravillas
y los músicos poetas iban ayudándoles a
hacer un recorrido por la lengua por el
desarrollo de la lengua española pero
también por la historia de la humanidad
los chicos pero avanzando en sus
estudios y llegaron a ser mis alumnos en
clases
yo les produce que se querían que jugara
las partes de poesía nuevamente y
elegancia nos producen quisiéramos allá
desde producción poética josé eustasio
rivera por muy mal
y muchos muchos cuentas más animales
los niños y las palabras
y mire usted es uno de los buenos
de poesía después de haber ido a la
ventana
y el amor tiene una mamá
ocurre que con la poesía necesitamos
vivir el texto tal cual fue escrito no
podemos contar la historia y tenemos el
juego
es tu hijo mío que más deben ser tesis
que yo antes obediente tan sólo porque
me gasté en la vencida y no la vergüenza
se atreverían a llamar desobedientes a
las nubes cuando mandan cuando usted
tiene una mamá y cuando regrese a su
mismo granja él le da un beso
este sentido que está el artista cuando
tenía presente
que ha sido el conflicto político
militar
recuerda que les dije en nuestro país
quizá ningún rincón rincón que no lo
haya sido
bueno los chicos si llevan escribiendo y
publicamos nuestro libro creo en la
poesía en el noble sentido de creer y de
crear
quiero terminar esta conversación con
ustedes con este poema
en este envío cuando tenía 14 años
como si se regalan
como si se regala la pintura de la super
vicio y se expandiera nubes en el cielo
así de bueno
con un niño perdido gritando y llorando
un poco el pintor se ha formado
es como un dolor que no se enturbie al
alma es un agua que no quiero beber más
yo no les voy a contar que me había
sucedido ahora vamos
yo solo quiero contarles que la poesía
les dio las almas
la libertad
y el poder de hablar en sus secretos sin
tener que encontrar sus secretos les
hizo sentir que este lugar también les
pertenecía y que estos dolores que
habían heredado sin hacer nada
no importa
que estuviera bien porque también
estaban las esperanzas porque saben que
vivir se encuentra en su oportunidad
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]